rather than give us Elden ring DLC news
at the game awards from software
revealed a whole new game armored Core
6. many fans were wondering whether this
game would take on a Souls aspect but a
new interview with IGN should quell that
expectation armored Core 6 will not be
like from software's souls or soulsborne
ring games it will be like older armored
Core games however it will share some
similarities to sekiro and I want to
talk a bit about the section of the
interview that talked about that since I
feel like it hasn't gotten covered as
much as the other points in the talk hi
everyone mad Luigi here with Elden ring
winning so many awards I figured I'd
talk about some of the game awards news
in the meantime that I'm working on
Elden ring lore for the Christmas season
so be on the lookout for those videos
and subscribe if you haven't to keep up
to date with that lore now let's get
into the video yesterday IGN released
the first focused interview on Armored
Core 6 featuring Elden ring director and
hitetake Miyazaki and sakuro lead
designer Masaru yamamura the interview
delved into what to expect from the
mecca series's first installment in a
decade with so much time since the last
armored Core from Saw fans like us have
largely come to expect a souls-born
experience from the studio leading to
questions about whether armored Core
will be more like armored Souls this
time around fortunately this interview
puts those questions to rest no it will
not and there's no place for confusion
since the interviewer referenced armored
Core being possibly like the souls games
over and over and over during the
interview now given the huge influence
that games like dark souls and Elden
ring have had on contemporary gaming
it's not surprising that an interviewer
would ask the director of those games
how they might impact or relate to the
Studio's newest title I'd say that's
good journalistic practice that said
Miyazaki was clear saying no we've not
been making a conscious effort to try to
direct it towards more soulsborne type
gameplay first of all let me just make
that clear and he went on to say that
while there may be some shared aspects
between the recent games and armored
Core 6. those elements are more
characteristic of from software than
they are specifically of the souls games
I think first of all speaking to those
aspects you mentioned the heavy combat
the air of mystery the exploration and
sense of Darkness I think rather than
being typically soulsborne these are
just things that are typical of from
software in general these are things
we've always sort of enjoyed and always
prided ourselves on so we can let that
fan Theory be put to rest however I do
want to touch on some other things said
in the interview by yamamura who did
make a slight comparison to sekiro when
I asked about what lessons he learned
from sekido and would be applying to ac6
now mamura said this there are no
elements directly referring to sekiro
but I feel both titles share the same
essence of battle such as aggressive
speed change and action-oriented
fighting for this title by continuing to
attack even the strongest enemy the
force of impact can break the enemy's
posture and inflict a large amount of
damage a critical hit this is the
starting point for the slow and fast
speed change of the battle and when
combined with long-range firefighting
and close range melee combat the enemy
and his machine engage each other
violently creating a more aggressive and
dynamic battle that only meccas can
engage in and to a follow-up question
yamamura continued rather than calling
it a counter mechanic what we want to
stress is this reason to continue
attacking and to continue on the
offensive you want to create chances for
yourself in combat and turn the battle
to the player's Advantage so what we
feel is this is going to create a really
nice back and forth flow in battles in
armored Core 6 and create this nice mix
of offensive and defensive play but we
want the player to feel like they're
constantly able to pressure the enemy
and that's why we incorporated some of
these systems which really does sound
like it could have been a description of
sekiro I felt like these quotes
highlight what should be a really big
they take away from the interview and
what to expect from ac6 and to be fair I
say this as someone who hasn't yet
played any of the previous armored Core
games so I can't really give independent
insight into the gameplay storytelling
or lore aspect of the series and how
they may function in this newest
installment and I think it's even more
important to hear these words since
yamamura is the lead director for ac6
the article notes that Miyazaki was in
his own words and initial game director
and it even continues saying Miyazaki
himself is largely taking a step back
from this project he jokes that he's
excited to play as a fan instead
providing the concept to Dark Souls
veteran Masaru yamamura the takeaway
here is that we can expect a flow of
combat in armored Core 6 something
similar yet of course distinct to what
we experienced in sekido which
definitely had more of a direct back and
forth between offense and defense than
other recent from soft games this will
be one of the more direct avenues that
from softcan put their recent experience
and new expertise to use even if they
all haven't been as direct with it as
sekito the souls games have all crafted
a compelling flow of Combat gameplay
requiring players to weave their attacks
in with their defensive plays whether
that be dodging dashing or blocking
after all the combat has been one of the
selling points of the series The Flow
fromsoft has gotten great at crafting
over the past decade should fortunately
be able to transfer over somewhat
smoothly to armored Core there are
plenty of aspects that Miyazaki and
yamamura noted about ac6 which will make
sure it's different from the souls games
things like individually segmented
missions and a huge focus on Mech
customization but the home stream of
gameplay the seamless back and forth
between delivering and avoiding damage
seems ripe to jump ship from the
post-apocalyptic fantasy series to the
post-apocalyptic Mecca one and we're
hearing all this from the top echelons
of from software that that is exactly
what is happening so it's pretty good
authority at this point I don't think I
can offer much more insight I think
these notes from yamamura speak for
themselves of course in the meantime
we'll be on the lookout for Elden ring
DLC news for the Trove of lore that will
surely be stick around the channel if
you're excited and looking forward to
that and thanks for watching the video
I'll see you in the next one peace